This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases. nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
Ford Post-Do and Pathology, Naturopathic
Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
>> Hello and welcome everyone. My name is
Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I want to welcome
you all to daily withda.
This program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
and if somebody referred you to this
program, please get back to that person
as they will be your main point of
contact. Um, and today we have the
amazing pharmacist Ben Fuches and we're
going to be revisiting and deep diving
into the question of why are people
afraid to take their supplements and
their medication or prescriptions at the
same time. So, we have some really good
questions on that. Pharmacist Ben is
going to fill us in. And this program is
for educational purposes only. It is not
meant to treat, diagnose or cure any
diseases and it is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Also, we do not make any claims
regarding health or income and as an
empire empowered individual, you do have
options. Also, if there is a
testimonial, it is the
experience of the person giving the
testimonial and not a claim that we are
making. So, I'm gonna go ahead and bring
Ben on. Who is
>> Hi there. I just had to detangle here.
Know why this always happens to me.
Not even sure what to do about it. Is
there a magic trick? Do you ever wonder
why like you wrap your iPhone or your um
your earphones in the in the drawer and
then like you open the drawer two days
later and it's all a big tangled mess?
>> I don't know. Are there little
>> like a physics law or something? I
always It's kind of crazy how that
happens. Anyway, how's it going, Ruth
Ellen?
>> It's going really good. How's it going
with you?
>> Good to see everybody.
Great to see you.
>> So, this is an interesting topic. Don't
you get frustrated when people say, "My
doctor said these are going to interfere
with my drugs or people ask." It's just
a kind of frustrating thing for me
because we have this kind of this this
sort of dual way of looking at medic at
nutrition. On one hand, we look at them,
and I don't mean by we, I, I mean the
mainstream, especially mainstream
medicine or the orthodox the orthodox um
medical viewpoint on nutrition is, oh,
it's just silly and you know, it doesn't
really work and there's no clinical
evidence and all that stuff. But on the
other hand, they're going to interfere
with your drugs. They're they're they're
so powerful that they have
pharmaceutical effects that are going to
counteract the medicines that we're
giving you. So, it's like, which one is
it? Are these really strong enough to
interfere with your medications? Are
they are they placeos and they don't
really work and there's no clinical
evidence and they're it's like taking
Skittles or M&M's, right? Well,
obviously obviously neither is true. And
the fact is nutrients are not drugs and
nutrients are not placeos. Body runs on
nutrients and they don't act like
pharmaceuticals. Pharmaceuticals
command
cellular responses. They order cellular
responses. They tell the cell what to
do. nutrients provide the right terrain
for the cells to do what they want to do
when they want to do it. Now, which one
makes more sense when it comes to a
therapeutic intervention to command to
order the cells to do things or to get
provide the the raw materials in a
environmental fashion in a terrain
fashion so the cells can be do what they
want to do and that's obviously that's
that's our perspective.
>> Yes, it is.
>> So then it comes to the interference
aspect.
>> Nutrients will not interfere with the
drugs literally or per se.
but they will create an environment
that allows the drug response to be more
effective. So to give a classic example,
if you are taking a bloodthinning drug,
they'll tell you not to use vitamin K
because vitamin K supposedly clots the
blood and they don't want to have a
blood clotting effect. Sorry, just one
second you guys. Hey, can I I got to
call you too. Okay.
Sorry, I had to do that. I was expecting
a phone call. So, um, so, uh, vitamin K
clots the blood supposedly. It doesn't
really clot the blood, but vitamin K
clots the blood and blood thinners thin
the blood. And so, if you take vitamin K
with your blood thinning drugs,
supposedly what's going to happen is
they're going to counteract each other.
That's not what happens. Vitamin K does
not clot the blood. Vitamin E does not
thin the blood. Essential fatty acids
don't thin the blood. And we and maybe
we're a little guilty for saying that as
lay people. We kind of confuse the
matter by talking that way. It's not
what happens. Vitamin E, essential fatty
acids, glucosamine,
um they have
effects that that allow the body to thin
the blood more effectively. Vitamin K
has effects that allows the blood to
clot more effectively. In other words,
when the body needs to clot, vitamin K
has to be present. No vitamin K present,
it's not going to clot as effectively.
But that's not the same as vitamin K
clotting the blood. You guys, is that
distinction clear? On the other hand,
>> a blood thinning drug like couadin
literally thins the blood. Literally
does not provide the environment, does
not provide the raw materials, does not
make it easier for the body to needs to
do. It literally thins the blood. And
the medical folks do not distinguish
between those two effects. We have to
distinguish between those two effects.
Providing the terrain, you know what I
mean when I say terrain. That's actually
a medical term. Terrain.
>> Yeah. The internal part of the body.
>> No, the terrain. The ground. Not the
internal part of the ground. Okay.
>> Right. So, the terrain is where the
plant grows from.
The terrain. A good terrain will allow a
plant to grow. A bad terrain will not
allow a plant to grow. We're working on
the terrain, the biochemical terrain to
allow biochemistry, biochemistry,
biochemistry to proceed, but we're not
with nutrition making things happen.
This is very important because to make
things happen is a a um a a command an
arrogant command proposal to the body.
You are going to do this. And I always
give that story about the, you know,
Moses hitting the rock because that's
what I always think of. You know, Moses
hit the rock. He wasn't supposed to hit
the rock. He's supposed to ask the rock.
Medicine hits the rock.
>> You are going to the doctor or the
medical professional saying blood
pressure, you're going to drop whether
you like it or not.
Gallbladder, we're going to take care of
you even if we have to yank you out of
the body. You understand this? It's a
different mentality
whether this happened or not. It's in
the it's at least legendary uh Francis
um Francis Bacon who was the father of
modern medicine one of the or modern
science one of the fathers of modern
science is famous for saying and this is
kind of legendary I'm not sure if he
literally said it but the legend goes he
said we will put nature on the rock and
tear her secrets from her limb from limb
and this is the viewpoint that science
and scientists had in the 1500s in the
16th century when science was getting
going and medicine is an extension of
It perceives nature as being flawed. It
perceives biology as being flawed. It
perceives the body as being inherently
flawed. And the only way that it can run
is if we fix it. We don't have that
perspective. Holistic practitioners
don't have that perspective. Naturopathy
doesn't have that perspective. Our
perspective is the body's wise, much
wiser than we are. And it seems pretty
self-evident.
Yes, there's heart attacks that happen
and there's there there's diseases that
happen clearly we obviously but the body
heals itself. Cells are capable of
producing hundreds of chemical reactions
a second with no intervention. So it
seems self-evident that the body knows
what it's doing and the only
interference that happens to it to to
keep it from running the way it's
supposed to be is us. We've seen the
enemy and he is us. And medicine is an
extension of that. And so when you ask
the question, will nutrients interfere
with my drugs? There's a implied
assumption that nutrients are like
drugs. They're not. They're the terrain.
We're working on providing the right
environment. That being said, by
providing the right environment
for the biochemistry to proceed the way
we want it to proceed, this will make it
easier for your drugs to work. If you
provide the right environment
nutritionally for the blood pressure for
the blood to thin and then you take a
blood thinner, you've provided the
environment now you don't need as much
blood thinner.
>> Do you follow my logic here?
>> Yes. Absolutely.
>> So nutrients make your drugs work
better.
>> In fact, they make it work so so much
better you have to tell your doctor
you're taking nutrients so you can lower
your dose.
And that's what we're looking to do
because what goes unspoken when we get
on prescriptions and there's people take
multiple prescriptions. Most people are
on who are taking prescriptions are on
multiple prescriptions. What goes
unstated is they're poisons.
>> They're toxins. And I'm not saying that
to insult or to be projorative.
I mean, literal. Your body has to
detoxify them. Detoxify them because
they're tox they're toxins.
So, they have to get processed like
toxins. So, the less you take, the
better you're going to be. So, the
physician should be saying, "Take lots
of nutrients and we'll just give you a
little bit of medication just to make
sure something happens." Or you're on
medication. Hey, I'm going to start
taking supplements. Great. Now, let's
lower your drug dose your drug. That's
what we're looking to do. If you're on a
prescription drug,
your number one health challenge is to
figure out how to take a lower dose and
wean yourself off that drug. And the
best way to do it is to fix the
building, is to fix the terrain, fix the
biochemistry. And that's what we're
doing. We're fixing the biochemistry.
Not we're not fixing it. We're providing
the resources for the body to fix the
biochemistry. And it's a it's a mindset.
It's a perspective that honors biology,
that honors biochemistry, that honors
the body, that honors divine
intelligence. There's none of that in
medicine. There's no honoring divine
intelligence in medicine. Medicine has
this this underlying assumption that
we're going to fix you. We don't need to
be fixed. We need to be fed. And that's
the message. So, nutrients will
interfere with your drugs in the sense
that they'll make it easier for your
drugs to do their to to do their work.
And on top of everything else, and this
is another point that goes unstated,
when you take vitamin K, it's not just
important for your blood. It's important
for your bones and it's important for
your skin and it's important for your
heart. So you could say, "Oh, well, we
don't want you to take vitamin K with
your blood thinner." Now, there's all
these other symptoms are all these other
systems are going to be deprived of
vitamin K. It's it's just doesn't make
it's so illogical. It's crazy. And
again, I hate to having to talk without
a doctor in front of me here. So, I'm
preaching to the choir. Let's get a
doctor on here and let's talk to them or
somebody who supports the medical model
because I hope this makes sense. Is this
make is this logical?
>> It does. It makes a lot of sense,
especially.
>> So, yes, they're going to interfere with
your drugs in the sense that you'll need
less drugs is the bottom line.
>> Yeah.
Very. Yes, that's very very true.
>> Okay, good. So, that's that's I get I
get a little ticked off when I hear
that. And sometimes they don't even say
don't take vitamin K. They'll say don't
eat broccoli. As if the only thing
broccoli is going to do is affect your
blood.
>> They literally tell you not to eat
broccoli.
>> They'll literally tell you not to eat
green leafy vegetables.
>> Yes, they do.
>> Yeah. You're not supposed to eat spinach
or kale or anything.
>> Right. Right. Because we want the drugs.
Now, I will say the doctors are
concerned that the and this is just, you
know, CYA. They do have liability.
They're concerned that because the
effects of the drugs are um
are are analyzed very closely. They're
monitored. They're parameters that the
drugs have to operate within and
nutrients are not that compliant because
nutrients are being shunted all over the
body. So the doctors are afraid that we
don't have enough control over the
nutrients. Like we have control over the
drugs. Of course, nobody has any control
over anything. you can't really control
the drugs, but they feel like they have
more control over the drugs and
nutrients will will um introduce a wild
card into the biochemistry and that's
what they're concerned about in
fairness, but they're so benign compared
to tox compared to toxic drugs. Docs
only look at one thing. They see
everything as pharmarmacology.
That's how they're trained because they
don't study nutrition. So, it's not like
they're bad people. It's not like
they're dumb people. They're trained
that way. They're trained to see every
intervention that get comes into the
body as a pharmacological intervention,
even if it's just food or nutritional
supplements.
>> Great.
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> So, what about the medication timing
>> between your supplements? Like, how do
you balance that?
>> It's occasionally you'll find some some
inter some it's very rare because
nutrients are so it's like food.
nutrients are
>> like when you take your drugs with your
nutrients kind of thing.
>> Yeah,
>> there's you with some exceptions like
antibiotics and probiotics possibly or
>> or vitamin C and certain minerals
possibly or or phitates or fiber and
certain nutrients um or maybe some uh
some drugs that uh that need to be stay
in the body a long time and nutrients
that facilitate digestion there's or
absorption or elimination.
>> For the most part, that's not a factor.
>> Okay.
very good.
>> For the most part, you can take you can
and should take your Mighty Nine
essential nutrients every single day,
even multiple times a day.
>> There's no downside to it. None.
>> Yeah.
>> Only upside. And they, like I said,
they'll only facilitate um and improve
your the effects of your drugs. By the
way, surgeries are another time when you
when it's really important to take med
to take nutritional supplementation to
get a better surgical outcome. So using
your Mighty 90 central nutrients as well
as things like your ultimate enzymes,
which aren't the Mighty 90. They'll give
you a better outcome. Using your healthy
bone and joint pack should be automatic
for everybody going through surgery.
Everybody going through surgery should
be on the healthy bone and joint pack
before and after with the digestive
enzymes. In fact, we should call the
healthy bone and joint pack the healthy
bone healthy bone and joint and
presurgical pack. That's how significant
that is. Everybody who's going through
some kind of surgical procedure will
have a better outcome from their
procedure if they're loaded with
nutrition pre-surgery, pre-surgery. As
soon as the scalp will hits the skin,
the healing process begins. So, if
you're loaded with vitamin C and calcium
and and magnesium and zinc, etc., etc.,
the healing process can begin instantly
as and that's when it should begin as
soon as the knife the scalpel hits the
skin.
>> Perfect. I agree with you. A friend of
mine had to have surgery not that long
ago and the she told them everything
that she was taking and the only thing
they really said she couldn't take was
the
>> essential fatty acids.
>> And why why is that?
>> Because of bleeding.
>> Because of bleeding. So they think in
their minds and it's silly but that's
how they think that essential fatty
acids are going to increase the
likelihood of you bleeding.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, and when in reality,
>> omega sixes and omega-3s balance each
other out. So, they're partially thin
the blood, partially clot the blood
because inflammatory inflammation,
anti-inflammation go hand in hand. So,
omega sixes have a pro-inflammatory
effect. Omega 3s have an
anti-inflammatory effect, but that
doesn't mean they'll cause inflammation
or they'll stop inflammation. They make
it easier for the body to inflame or
make it easier for the body to
anti-inflame. Does that that's a very
important distinction to make it easier
for the body to do what it what it wants
to do versus making the body do what it
wants to do. Hitting the rock versus
asking the rock.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, your body is your baby.
>> Love your baby. Be kind to your baby.
>> Yes.
>> It's this body, you know,
>> it's hard to really express how
miraculous this thing is. how how
integrated and networked and how
responsive and intelligent it is and we
from the cellular level to the organ
level. It's just mind-blowing and we
really need to sit with that and honor
that. And it would be it would be uh
very not only educational but
inspirational
to just think about your heart and what
your heart does or your intestine or
your liver or your spleen. Just sit with
it for five minutes. Just get on YouTube
and and do uh ask for an animation or
watch an animation of how your liver
works and then picture this thing in
your body. You know, partially it's like
we don't want to think about our organs,
right? Like do you want to think about
your liver? Do you want to ever see your
liver, right? We kind of block it out.
We sort of block it out because we don't
think about it. You know, if you ever
see the inside of your body, that's not
a good thing. but to use your
imagination and go into that and see how
everything's embedded in this matrix and
it's all connected to each other and how
what happens on the you know uh what is
how does that go AJ a butterfly flaps
his wings in South America and somebody
catches a cold in China it's like it's
all integrated there's it's all
connected every single iota every single
piece of the body is integrated with
everything else like a hologram it's all
one thing and it's just so miraculous
and amazing thing, but because there's
some kind of block that we have, we
don't like thinking about it. It allows
us to swallow poisons that will shut
down cholesterol production or force our
blood to clot or thin. It's it's a in
philosophy, there's this idea called
absurdio adred reductum. Have you heard
of that? Absurdio adred reductum. It's a
philosophical idea that says you take
the most extreme and absurd case to
prove your point. absurd. Our idea that
we can drug the body into submission to
have it get healthier or somehow be
healthier is absurd reductive. It's the
most it's the extent of the most
ridiculous idea you can think of. And
when it started in in the middle of the
19th century with with um aspirin or
what they called aspirin back then I
think pretty sure that was one of the
early drugs that was that was great. But
it's got proceeded on to this crazy uh
point where we're spending literally
hundreds of billions if not trillions of
dollars on these things. People are on
five, six, 10 medications and it's it's
getting worse every year. Are we getting
healthier for all that? Ask yourself
that. Are we getting healthier for all
the medication we're taking, which
increases every year? When I was doing
my pharmacy stuff, it would not be
unusual for somebody to take a plastic
bag, an older person, usually a plastic
bag and throw it on the counter with 10
different bottles in there and then they
would go shop and I would fill 10
different bottles for the same person.
And the situation's only gotten worse.
It's an it's absolutely absurd absurd
reduct. It's the most absurd case you
could possibly imagine when uh when it
comes to uh when it comes to health and
wellness.
>> I agree with you. And we're all
responsible, by the way. All of us. It's
not just the doctor's fault. It's all of
us for participating in this.
>> And and there's probably people out
there thinking, "Oh, this is just crazy
hippie talk and blah blah blah, new age,
blah blah blah blah blah blah." Not not
probably not the people on the call, you
know, who are on the call regularly, but
there's a lot of people think that this
is just crazy talk, you know. In fact,
most people do.
>> Yeah. So, we have a couple hands up.
Would you like to take questions?
>> Yes, I would love to take questions.
>> All right, Mary, if you can unmute. I'm
going to bring you on screen
and
>> hello Mary.
>> Hey,
how you doing?
>> I'm doing good. How are you doing?
>> Good. Good. I was along with you filling
all those prescriptions. You
>> were you a pharmacist?
>> No, I was the pharmacist technician.
>> Ah, you know what I'm talking about,
right?
>> Oh, of course.
>> A plastic bag with like 10 different
bottles in it, right? Yes.
>> And that was not unusual.
>> Not unusual. Not unusual. Um, okay. So,
let's get to some questions. I'll just
take two. There's many, so I'm gonna try
to get it quick here. Um, Mark has a
question.
>> Yes, I know.
>> Are there any natural remedies to help
fight ulcerative colitis? Oh, yes. No,
he knows about reducing in reducing
inflammation helps,
>> but he knows foods. The most important
thing for any intestinal problem,
ulcerative colitis, is it's not really
disease. It's a description. You got
ulcers in your colon.
>> Yeah. Ulceration occurs when there's
toxicity in the colon, when there's
changes in bacteria, so-called
disbiosis, or in response to specific
foods. So, the most important thing is
food.
Eliminate all the problem foods,
liquid diet, possibly depending on how
how severe the ulceration is. Uh, slimy
stuff. So bone soup, bone broth
is ideal, aloe vera gel, um alo
fucoidin, fucoid z or maybe even
zeratic. Uh something to coat the the
the ulcer is a good idea. Healthy uh
healthy digestion pack.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh nightly essence. You got to be a
little bit careful with the nightly
essence. You want to start off slowly
with probiotics because if you have too
much bacteria in the intestine, you can
throw things off. So you want to start
off slowly. I26. Of course, the Daily
Digest is cool because it comes in a
packet and you can take a bunch of
different supplements all in one packet
every day. So, that's a good idea to
use. Dr. Ariz's liver cleanse is a good
idea to use. There's a very important
relationship between the intestine and
the um and the uh and the colon. I'm
sorry, the intestine and the liver. And
then also strengthening the um the
intestinal lining with collagen
peptides, collagen, fucoid, and fucoid Z
um healthy bone and joint pack. The
healthy bone and joint pack as we talked
about earlier is good for the whole
body. That's just the bones and joints
for the connective tissue and there's a
very important connective tissue
component to the intestine. So
ulcerative colitis in many ways in many
ways involves deterioration of
connective tissue. So healthy bone and
joint pack. So there's lots and lots and
lots of things to do. Most importantly
is to stop the assaults on the intestine
and don't go by good food bad food list
because there's a lot of good foods that
can create havoc in the intestine. So
you want you want to do a food diary and
look for symptoms, ulcerative colitis,
any digestive issue, Crohn's disease,
celiac disease, ulcerative colitis,
whatever it is, all of it, all of it is
reversible. The intestine and the skin
are the two most the cells of the
intestine and the cells of the skin are
the two most rapidly dividing cellular
systems in the body. So they're designed
to heal. Think about it. The intestine
is constantly being assaulted, if you
will, even from a healthy diet.
>> Yeah.
>> So, nature has equipped the intestine
with rapid cellular division. So, yes,
they can heal. You can never have
ulcerative colitis again if you ever do
that. If if you do this correctly, how
cool is that? You can never have to deal
with this condition again. It's strictly
a food condition.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, by modifying the way you eat and
modifying the kind of supplements you
take, you can do a lot. I I highly
recommend liquids um in addition to bone
soup, vegetable juices, but you got to
be careful with some vegetables. So, you
may want to make sure that that you're
doing the right vegetables, but between
vegetable juices, bone soup, aloe vera,
um you can definitely definitely help
soothe and accelerate healing of the
intestine. Vitamin A, by the way, is
very important for intestinal health,
for cell division.
>> Perfect. Perfect. And fortunately, many
of our products can be in liquid form,
so they can be taken much easier.
glucco gel caps too or glucco gel liquid
I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, liquid glucco gel. Okay, perfect.
The second one I'll ask is um from
Julia. Uh she asks, "I am almost 70
years old, type 2 diabetes and high
blood pressure and neuropathy
and knee ligament issues. What's the
best best
>> diet and best vitamins and minerals?"
>> Triangle of disease. That's the second
point on the triangle of disease
>> which of course involves the first point
you know which we don't talk about a lot
but if you have a second point you gota
have the first point to the first point
precedes it. So aside from the first
point which is all the digestive stuff
that we just talked about and remember
and I this is not something people
really address but we do on this program
so I'll just say I'll say it again even
though you know we say it all the time.
There's a very important connection
between the gallbladder, the liver and
the intestine and blood sugar. This is
how the first point becomes the second
point. Bile is like a hormone that
communicates to the blood sugar system
to the metabolic system.
>> The intestine is communicating to the
metabolic system. This is why GLP-1s
affect the intestine and that's why GLP
uh the most important side effects for
GLP-1s are intestinal because of the
relationship between the liver and and
there's the liver which obviously
metabolizes sugars. So it's a short jump
from digestive dysfunction to metabolic
or blood sugar dysfunction. I'm not
going to talk about that but to strictly
address blood sugar.
>> Look how does blood sugar get elevated?
There's only two ways.
>> There's only two ways your blood sugar
there changes are created in blood
sugar. Number one, obviously food and
number two, cortisol, stress hormone.
>> So between blood, between food and and
stress hormone, you have your two major
leverage points.
>> And I don't know if I talked about this
last time. I think I talked about it on
coast to coast. The because the body is
a system.
Meaning the definition of a system is a
bunch of parts that work together for
one goal. And that's the body.
>> Yeah.
>> All the parts are working together for
one goal. This idea of a system is
something that has only been articulated
and elucidated in science for about 60
about 70 years since the 1940s. Before
that we didn't really have an
understanding what symptoms was. We had
a sort of intuitive probably
understanding but from a scientific
perspective systems theory
>> began in in the 1940s.
Today we can we can take systems theory
which began as from cybernetics and
computers and we can apply it to the
body. We can apply systems theory and
all the hallmarks and pillars of systems
theory to biology and biochemistry. And
one of the key hallmarks of systems
theory is that all systems have control
points,
leverage points, bottlenecks, however
you want to call it, but points where
you can make a little twist and you can
affect the entire system. Contrast
that with how medicine looks at the body
which comes from as I said earlier the
15th century and 16th century where all
the parts were looked at as being
independent.
They weren't looked at as being part of
a system. So if you had a heart problem,
you had a heart problem. If you had a
skin problem, you had a skin problem.
You had a bone problem, you had a bone
problem. With systems theory, if you had
a bone problem, you got a system
problem. With a skin problem, you got a
system problem. The old ways you got a
bone problem, you got a bone problem. So
the beautiful thing about systems, it
allows you to leverage these control
points. The major control point is what
comes into the body through the mouth
and that's food. So for our friend,
what's her name? This gal,
>> Julia,
>> food, food, food, food, food.
>> The less you eat, the the more stable
your blood sugar system is going to be.
The less calories you ingest, the more
stable your blood sugar is going to be.
The less foods you ingest that spike
your calories or spike your blood sugar,
the more stable your blood sugar is
going to be. So stay away from foods
that are fast burning, highly uh easy to
process.
Uh fast food, processed food,
ultrarocessed food is engineered
to be easy to process.
There's no ultrarocessed food that you
have to chew a lot for example, right?
You have to chew a food a lot. That's
usually a a natural food.
>> Fast food, ultrarocessed food, it goes
right down your throat. It goes right in
your system. These spike your blood
sugar instantly.
Foods that have lots of fructose, fruit
sugar, high fructose corn syrup, same
thing.
Sweets, beverages,
sweet beverages I should say, they're
the worst. And that includes fruit
juice, the worst. But especially sodas
and and uh what they call soft drinks,
right? You're better off having a hard
drink than a soft drink from a from a
metabolic perspective. Yes, you are
really.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, not that a hard drink's great
for you either, but the soft drinks will
kill you slowly. Fatty liver disease is
an epidemic now largely because of our
inc our our dramatically increased
ingestion of fructose not in fruits but
in high fructose corn syrup. Healthy
blood sugar pack for our uh what's her
name? Say her friend. Julia,
>> for Julia, healthy blood sugar pack. In
addition to a healthy blood sugar pack,
before every meal or at the start of
every meal, I should say, make sure
you're eating protein and vegetables.
Have your bread and have your sweets and
have your anything that spikes your
blood sugar after you have your protein
and your vegetables.
In the middle of the day, do a fiber
drink. Grind up flax seeds and put it in
water and drink it. And that will fill
you up. And so you'll be be less likely
to snack. nutrients that are important
or or products that are important or
helpful aside from the ones in the
healthy blood sugar pack. Ultimate
NASCI,
>> ultimate selenium, ultimate MSM, CFX,
zinc FX, these will all support blood
sugar metabolism. Osteomag all support
blood sugar metabolism. So you have so
many different ways, so many different
It's so ironic to me that the the
leading cause of death in this country
is blood sugar, elevated blood sugar.
Now the two the two cause there's two
major causes of death cancer and heart
disease that if you look at the
statistics come before diabetes as a
cause of death. So diabetes is
technically the third leading cause of
death but both cancer and cardiovascular
health or heart disease is a form of
diabetes is a form of dislycemia messed
up blood sugar. So all our health
challenges our long-term health
challenges have a major blood sugar
component. And it's so ironic to me
because it's that's the easiest thing to
correct.
>> The easiest thing to correct from a
physiological perspective. Maybe not
from a mental perspective or a
psychological perspective because we
love our sweets and and and we're our
brains are programmed to feel pleasure
>> when we eat high calorie foods. When we
eat what they call hyper palatable
foods, they actually literally call them
hyper palatable, super tasty. when we
eat these kinds of foods that give us a
big payoff, a big caloric payoff or a
big pleasure payoff, how you going to
tell somebody not to eat their Ben &
Jerry's, you know, when you get this
kind of pleasure sensation. So, it does
require a certain a certain amount of
willpower, a certain amount of
discipline, but there are hacks you
could do like the nutritional hacks that
we talked about. Uh the B vitamins in
particular in the Beyond Tangy Tangerine
can be a nutritional hack. Drinking more
water. Just drinking more water can be
an important nutritional hack for type
two diabetics or even type one diab or
everybody who's dislycemic without being
diagnosed. Drinking more water will
dilute your sugar, dilute your blood, so
your blood sugar concentration will drop
especially first thing in the morning.
>> Got it. Got it. Two two follow-ups on
that. Um one is there you said eat as
little as possible. Is there a minimal
amount? No, there's no. Everybody's
going to be different less way nutrients
needed.
>> No, you don't want to think that way.
Everybody's going to be different. But
every single study that's ever been done
on longevity has shown the less you eat,
the longer you live.
>> Obviously, without starving. There are
nutrient sensors in every cell that will
sense nutritional status, the amount of
nutrients that are present.
>> And you're going to hear more about this
as time goes on because they just kind
of discovered this about 30 years ago.
There's a there's actually a complex a
molecular complex in cells called mTor.
>> Have you heard of this molecular target
of rapamy? MTOR. You're going to hear
more and more about this over the coming
years. MTOR is your major nutrient
sensor in the body. When mTor sensors
nutrients, macronutrients largely
actually mostly macronutrients, mostly
sugar, it will turn on cell chemistry.
In other words, from an evolutionary
perspective, that meant it was
summertime and it's time to grow. You
got plenty of food. You just ate a
woolly mammoth. You just ate a
saber-tooth tight, whatever it is you
ate when you were a caveman. So, the
mtor senses there's resources present.
It says, "Let's get going. Let's make
connective tissue. Let's make collagen.
Let's make cells divide. Let's start
moving. This is
>> obviously makes sense for the body. It
goes to sleep when there's not nutrients
present and it revs up when there are
nutrients present." What we have done
over the last 100 years for economic
reasons, unbeknownst to us, because we
didn't understand biochemistry 100 years
ago,
is we've created a food system that's
designed to drive food into human
bodies. You know, they sometimes on
Facebook they'll show you pictures of uh
people at the beach in the 1960s and
1970s comp. Have you seen this?
>> Yes.
>> Compared to people on the beach now or
they'll show you people walking in New
York City in the 1920s compared to
people walking in New York City now. You
see the difference? And this is what's
happened over the last 40 or 50 years
our in our lifetime. It's become an
epidemic of obesity, an epidemic of
excess calories and excess calorie
driven health challenges. One of the
things that happens, by the way, when
mTor is activated is the body will start
pumping out cholesterol.
And you know, our medical folks, because
they're not biochemists, they're
clinicians, will say, "You got too much
cholesterol. Let's shut down the
cholesterol production." Not, "Why is
the cholesterol production so high?" But
cholesterol is high and there's lots of
cholesterol. We're just going to knock
it out. That's the way they think.
Cholesterol, elevated cholesterol is a
classic sign of the cells thinking
there's plenty of resources and it's
time to make stuff. Cholesterol is a
fundamental building block for making
things. Right. So we the more calories
we ingest particularly from from sugars,
the more mTor the the faster mTor is
going to the more efficiently mTor is
going to kick in and the more
cholesterol and other substances you're
going to make. This is why slowing the
body down, calming the body down is your
most important strategy for health and
longevity, particularly if you're sick,
particularly if you're not if you're if
you're dealing with some kind of chronic
health challenge. Slow everything down.
>> You got it. Perfect. Thank you. By the
way, what nutrients allow you to do is
allow you to get torque versus speed.
You know, on your on your bicycle, you
can put it up to you put it to the first
gear, you get speed. You can turn the
the wheels really fast. But if you go
down to 10, you get torque. So, one push
gives you much more power, much you get
to move more per push. We want torque,
not speed. You get torque from
nutrition. Micronutrients particularly,
you get torque from micronutrients.
Micronutrition.
>> Perfect. Thank you so much for that
answer. I'll turn it over to either Ruth
Ellen or AJ.
>> Thank you so much, Mary. AJ, you have
your hand up. I'm going to bring you on.
And
if you could unmute, that would be
awesome.
>> Well, Mrs. Ben, how are you today?
>> I'm good. AJ, good to see you.
>> Good to see you as well. And uh a lot of
people really appreciate what you do uh
every day, but in particular on Coast to
Coast, they really appreciate hearing
from you.
>> Thank you. I'm glad I'm glad I'm
appreciated. It's nice to be
appreciated.
>> Yes, you are well appreciated. You know,
I have a woman named Sally.
>> Yeah.
>> In California dealing with
uh I don't know if this word is
accurate. Cameron lesions
elongated flattened ulcers bleed at
bleeding at the crest of the stomach
folds. Large hiatal hernia problem looks
okay except for the fact that there's
mild diverticulitis.
Six since last year. Uh too high of a
risk to have surgery. She's got to lose
some weight first. Shortness of breath.
Difficulty walking.
>> All right. You can stop right there.
MBFA.
classic classic MBFA
Cameron lesions just they're just
ulcerations basically stomach
ulcerations and that's what's happening
her whole digestive tract is ulcerated
but she's also got weight problems so
chances are she's dislycemic
>> I'm sure H pylori is involved absolutely
um and then she didn't mention it but
she's probably got problems sleeping and
she's probably got jitteriness and
anxiety and all the all the cortisol
issues as well
>> what does that what does that scream out
to you there
>> digestive problems blood sugar problems,
adrenal stress problems.
>> Well, besides the triangle of disease,
it reminds me of metabolic syndrome, but
>> well, that's the second point on the
triangle of disease. Yes, it's metabolic
syndrome. Absolutely. So, the same
thing. And yeah,
>> uh proton pump inhibitor.
>> That's just a drug that stops her body
from making acid. Just doctor nonsense.
She may need it, you know, because
acid's obviously going to make cause a
problem, but acid will also keep her
from absorbing her minerals and her B
vitamins and breaking down her proteins
and activating her enzymes. So, you
know, this is just the doctor mentality.
And I'm not blaming doctors because
that's how they're trained. See problem,
fix problem, right? That's that's not
how it works. You don't see problem, fix
problem. You got to see problem and
backtrack to where the problem begins if
you really want to help. But that's not
that's not what we do. Look, we're going
to do we're going to the doctor. The
doctor didn't come to this lady and say,
"Let me help you." She went to the
doctor. So, you get what the you get
whatever the doctor does. You know, it's
like uh you know, one day I don't have a
lot time. and remind me to tell you the
the story about the moth who goes into
the podiatrist's office.
>> And what did he say?
>> Um he says the moth goes into the
podiatrist's office and he starts
talking about his problems with his feet
and he says, "Oh my god, you know, I
can't walk and you the moth says my feet
hurt and this that and the other." And
the podiatrist says, "I'm a podiatrist.
Why'd you come to see me?" And and the
moth says, "Oh no, no, I'm sorry." The
guy moth goes in the podiatrist. The
moth starts talking about his
psychological problem. Says, "Oh my god,
my my Mrs. moth left me and my little
moth kids are mad at me and I lost my
little moth job and the podiatrist said
why you come to me I'm a podiatrist and
the the moth says the light was on
I know I I messed up the joke but that's
kind of like that we go to them they
don't come to us
>> you know
>> so we go to them we're going to get what
they treat us listen to help this lady
work on the digestive system rewind I'm
not going to repeat it just rewind what
we just talked about with the digestive
You see I'm repeat you see how these
things repeat themselves. There's
nothing special. Only specialists think
there's something special. There's
nothing special. It's generic. The body
breaks down in a predictable pathway.
You know, sometimes somebody will tell
me a couple things about their health
and then I'll tell them about their
menstrual cycle or they'll tell I'll
tell them about their sleep issues or
they'll tell them about their fertility
and they'll say, "How did you know
that?" Because it's a pattern. It all
it's all repeats itself. There's nothing
special about how the body breaks down.
It's generic. And that's why the mindset
is so important. But we don't believe in
ourselves. And partially it's because
we're taught not to believe in
ourselves. We're taught to trust other
people. That's why I always harp on this
idea of authority. You want to be your
own authority. Youngevity is about being
your own doctor. What? Let's play
doctor, right? This is what doc was all
about. Do it yourself. So for this gal,
her body's falling apart largely at the
at the first point based on what you
said. Now, she also has obesity issues,
so there's metabolic issues, I'm sure.
And like I said, she didn't mention
cortisol, but I'm sure there's sleep
problems, anxiety issues, depression,
and all the things that are associated
with cortisol. Foods, food diary. We got
a food diary at criticalnews.com.
Everybody who's dealing with a chronic
degenerative condition or or multiple
chronic degenerative conditions,
download that food diary and start doing
the food diary and link your pro your uh
health issues with specific foods. Then
eliminate those foods and then you do
all the digestive stuff we just talked
about and then get on the blood sugar
stuff that we just talked about. Go
ketogenic, low calorie, low sugar, etc.
It's as simple as that. Healthy blood
sugar pack, bucoid Z, I26, Daily Digest,
Ultimate Enzymes, apple cider vinegar,
or even better, Beyond Tangy Tangerine.
Drink your Beyond Tangy Tangerine with
your Ultimate Enzymes. Drink Beyond
Tangy Tangerine with your meals. You'll
get better absorption of your Beyond
Tangy Tangerine. And you'll mitigate
some of the digestive the the blo the
bloating and cramping and and and
diarrhea that occurs sometimes with
Beyond Tangy Tangerine when you take too
much. You can mitigate that by having
food that will slow down the release of
the BTT and it will help you digest your
food as well. So there's there's all of
these wonderful strategies that you
employ. Here's the good news.
The sicker you are, the faster the
turnaround begins. So for those last two
questions that you ask me, you can turn
this around today, today, after this
call, during this call, between
cigarettes, your lungs start to heal.
Between assaults to the body, whatever
those assaults are, your body heals
between meals, your intestine, your your
diverticulitis, your hammer lesions,
they will begin healing. So as soon as
you put stop putting the salts into the
body, the healing process begins.
Especially if you have nutrients in
there.
understood pharmacist Ben and you know I
feel bad for people they call in they
don't feel like they have any hope
>> yeah you know they feel overwhelmed so
they will go yes
>> and they'll get the temp the temporary
fix
>> yes
>> the long term you know use like you this
show is titled use your nutrients
alongside with your medication and
hopefully soon you won't need your
medication
>> work with your doctor work with your
physician don't Don't let him tell you
not to take the nutrients. Say, "I am
going to take the nutrients, doctor.
It's in my body. I'm going to take them.
I'll let you know what I'm doing. We'll
monitor everything. It's your right to
take nutrients." Don't let anybody tell
you it's not in your health interest to
be on a supplementation program. That's
not true. That's blatantly not true. So,
you it's your right to do that. Unless
you're in a hospital, I guess, you know,
if you're in a hospital, they own you.
You can't do it then. But at home, it's
your right to do that. Just tell the
doctor, I'm going to work with you, but
I'm taking my magnesium. I'm taking my
vitamin E, my EFAS, my my um whatever it
is, my uh osteomag or whatever. What?
Tangy tangerine. Exactly.
>> And by the way, and just you know uh how
important the food diary is. Everyone
should go to critical health news, sign
up for the newsletter, and get a copy of
the food diary. And then you want to
call 855-949-3377.
talk to the team because we have a tool
that I created that you can utilize to
help you analyze the food diary based on
what pharmacist Ben and Dr. Wallock have
taught us. Pharmacist Ben, see you
Monday night.
>> See you Monday night. What you're going
or I'm going
>> you're muted.
>> Thank you. AJ,
>> why did he say see you Monday night?
What do you He's left the screen and we
Phyllis has her hand up and he may not
come back on screen until the end.
>> Okay. Gotcha. Okay. All right.
>> I thought he was kicking me off.
>> No, no, no. We still have, you know, 15
minutes with you. So, we're gonna try
and get as many questions as we can in.
>> One time I worked I had this job working
for this guy and he was an older guy and
he wanted to be really he was he was
really sweet. He was really nice, but
but he wanted to he wanted to fire me
and uh his way of firing he goes when I
left one one day for he go well I guess
we won't be seeing you around these
parts anymore Ben that's his way
>> that's terrible
>> that's how he fired me
>> I won't be seeing you around these parts
any such a nice guy he couldn't fire me
>> oh my gosh I cannot believe that was
just
>> I know my gosh
>> All right so let's go ahead
Well, and thank you for
>> Well, you're cracking me up between that
and the moth.
>> I've ruined the moth joke, but it is
it's funnier than it than I thought.
>> It was It was still funny.
>> Okay, so we have a couple of questions
from Repulsify on YouTube.
>> What? Repulsify.
>> I know. I know. Great name.
>> Terrible name.
>> Repulsify. All right.
All right. Well, um, so f number one,
>> yes,
>> he he asks, "What do you know about
AKG?"
>> What about What do I know about AKG?
Okay. What's the next question?
>> I'll tell you about AKG in a second.
>> All right. Um, so he says his hairline
is receding from the corners. He started
that male pattern baldness. His
appendix, he got his appendix out when
he was 10. He's
>> Well, there you go. Oh, you got one. You
got the problem right there. And a lot
of kids who have their appendix out are
going to be dealing with help with well,
first of all, they're going to be
dealing with intestinal problems for the
rest of their life, but they've also had
intestinal problems that preceded
the their appendicitis or their appendic
appendix removal. The appendix is a
little tiny stick, a little tiny tube
that comes off of the intestine. And for
the longest time, they didn't know what
it did. They used to when I was in
pharmacy school, they used to call a
vestage, meaning it's just some useless
piece of flesh that's in the body that
there's no purpose for. But then they
realized that that's where all the
bacteria are. And it turns out that the
appendix is a warehouse or storehouse
for bacteria.
So without an appendix, you're going to
be dealing with dispiosis for the rest
of your life unless you take care of
yourself. And then preceding the
appendix if he had appendicitis I assume
he had appendicitis he probably had
dispiosis before that. So he this is a
guy who has long-standing digestive
health issues or long-standing yes
long-standing digestive health issues.
What was the question about it?
>> Does he have a question about
>> um he asked about his hairline receding
but he also mentioned uh talk about the
dispiosis. He's 209bs 510 and he has
brown circular marks on his skin which
does that relate to the digestion?
Absolutely 100%. The skin and the
digestive system are are like two peas
in a pot. The digestive system is the
skin inside out and vice versa. The skin
is a digestive system outside in. They
communicate to each other and it's
almost impossible to have a a skin
condition that's not a digestive
condition. There are some local things
like um gluten allergies or nickel
allergies or latex allergies, but even
then a case could be made that the skin
is sensitive because of digestive
issues. So, you want to pretty much
assume that a skin problem is a
digestive problem. I'm saying that as
somebody who's been studying skin and
skin issues for 40 plus years. It's
almost impossible not to have one
related to the other. The f uh the hair
problem is a follicle problem.
>> When you have hair loss, you've got
follicles that aren't feeding hair. The
follicles are lined by like any other
part of the body like by cells. So, it's
a cellular issue. To the body, the hair
doesn't matter. To us it matters but to
the body the heart is way more important
than the hair and the spleen and the
liver and the intestine and the lungs
and all the internal viscera are way
more important than the hair is. So
under conditions of nutritional
deficiencies or toxicities all the
resources are going to be diverted from
the top from the extremities into the
center the viscera the the core of the
body. So until you get that straightened
out you're not going to be able to deal
with your hair. You can't deal with it
directly. So the body doesn't give a
rat's you know what about your hair. Ra
body is much more concerned with your
survival and hair has nothing to do with
your survival as much as we like hair.
There's also the issue of hormones.
Testosterone and insulin are major
players in hair loss. Obviously, if this
guy is 510 and 209, he's got some
insulin problems and likely has
testosterone problems. So, you can't,
and this is also true for men who have
ED or men who are starting to lose their
masculinity as they get older or men who
are starting to lose muscle mass or
weaker as they get older. Think insulin.
Elevated insulin.
Once you have elevated insulin, it's a
very, very short jump to deficiencies or
at least functional deficiencies in
testosterone and androgens and male
hormones. Think insulin. How do you how
do you lower insulin? Lower your
calories. It's a well-known fact that
anabolism and muscle building can be
accomplished by calorie reduction. Not
nutrition reduction, but calorie
reduction. Bodybuilders know this. you
know before before contest they'll fast
they won't eat so they can get cut up so
work on your insulin there's a major
connection between elevated insulin and
hair loss it's part of metabolic
syndrome as Ruth Ellen could tell or as
uh Rebecca could tell us if she was here
so think insulin resistance remember
we're boiling this down to the control
points the control points are the the
three major control points are the
digestive system the blood sugar system
and the adrenal thyroid complex two
major control points if you want to
simplify even further are for the
digestive system and the metabolic
system. Period. Now, as far as AKG goes,
that is cute. You got way bigger fish to
fry than AKG. AKG, by the way, is um is
a a um um molecule that's involved in
the in energy production. Alpha
ketoglutarate they call it, or AKG.
Bodybuilders will sometimes use it.
They'll use it to reduce health
problems. Don't fall for it. You got way
bigger fish to fry than AKG. And anybody
tries to sell you AKG doesn't know what
they're talking about. You need your B
vitamins. You need your essential
nutrients. Remember, we call these the
mighty 90 essential nutrients. What does
that mean? That means without them,
you're dead. That's what essential
means. Sometimes people will say, "Oh,
essential means your body can't make it.
You got to get in your diet." It's more
fundamental than that. Without it,
you're dead. That's what it is. Or if
you don't have enough of it, you'll
suffer from a disease. Most of us are in
that category unless perhaps present
company excluded because we're all
hipped to supplementation. For most
people, they're going to be deficient in
the essential nutrients. Not enough to
be dead, but enough to be suffering from
health challenges from uh deficiency
deficiency health challenges, even if
they're not diseases. That's your fish.
Those are the fish you want to fry. AKG
is way down the list on important things
to do. It's cute. Don't waste your
money. Get on the healthy star pack.
>> So, besides cutting back on calories and
getting healthy Yeah. healthy blood
sugar pack.
>> What about upping his protein?
>> You know, that's that can help, but
especially before meals because that
will help him reduce his sugar intake.
Eating more protein is a great strategy
for reducing your your sugar intake
because sugar protein will get converted
into sugar.
Protein gets converted into sugar. This
is, by the way, one reason why sometimes
people wonder why they're not losing
weight when they go paleo or they go
high protein and they'll notice that
their blood sugar isn't changing
significantly or they're not losing
weight. And that's because protein does
get turned into sugar pretty relatively
efficiently. So, you got to be a little
bit careful with the protein. However,
protein will give you slow release of
sugar. It's not so much the sugar that's
the problem, although that's the
problem, too, but it's the fast release.
That's what they call the glycemic
index. The high glycemic index sugars
are the ones that get released really
fast into the bloodstream. Boom. They
spike the blood sugar. The body doesn't
like spikes. The body likes to be just
new, you know, just level, maybe a
little bump and then level, a little
bump. When you eat, you know, a dessert
or a soda or fruit juice, boom, your
blood sugar goes up. With protein, the
blood sugar stay stable. You get a
little bump as the as the protein gets
metabolized and sugars released
gradually. That's how you want to treat
the body. kindly, lovingly, pet the
body. You want everything calm with the
body, relax with the body. It's the
spikes that are the problem.
>> Well, I'll sign off by saying the body
wants to be just right.
>> Body wants to be just right. And thanks
for doing our book, Phyllis. Thanks for
I really appreciate that.
>> It's It's just been a joy so far.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Phyllis. And Mary, I'm gonna
go ahead and bring you on.
There you go.
Okay, I'm back.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay, we have a few more questions.
Hopefully, we can fit in to the hour.
Uh, one from Ellen. How to rebuild or
strengthen knee cartilage.
>> Same thing as everything else. Healthy
bone and joint pack. First of all,
obviously the knee cartilage is is
joint. The cartilage is the part of the
body called the connective tissue. Mhm.
>> And without, you know, to simplify
things, so it's not all weird and
scientific and, you know, bi biological.
It's just stuff.
>> The body's made of four kinds of stuff.
I know probably people have heard me say
it before, but it bears repeating. The
body is made up of four kinds of stuff.
>> Technically stuff, the word for stuff is
tissue. The four kinds of tissue, but I
call it stuff. You got the covering.
That's called epithelial tissue. Your
skin is epithelial tissue. Your eyes are
epithelial tissue. certain glands or
epithelial tissue. That's the covering
tissue. Then there's electrical wiring.
That's the nervous tissue. Then there's
the flesh robot, the part in the middle
that's underneath this, the covering.
The flesh robot, when when you see a
flesh robot, if you've ever seen the
bodies exhibit in the museums, you can't
tell whether the flesh robot is a
Chinese person or American or an Indian
or a black person or, you know, or
yellow or whatever. That the flesh robot
is just connective tissue and muscle
tissue. And that's who we are. That's
the bulk of who we are. Everything else
is just covering and wiring. That's the
part of the body that deteriorates
maximally as we age. Everything
deteriorates, but maximally that's the
part that deteriorates as we age. That's
the part that we go to to s have plastic
surgery for or we go to have tummy tucks
for or we go to have all the cosmetic
kinds of surgical interventions that we
go that we go to the the plastic surgeon
and and the and the um and the
physicians for because that's the part
that causes the most distress. The
muscle tissue and the connective tissue.
The sples robot if you cut it this way
like a cross-section you get stake. A
stake is muscle tissue and connective
tissue. The gristle on the white part,
that's the connective tissue. The red
part is the muscle tissue. The
connective tissue feeds the muscle
tissue. The connective tissue feeds
everything. So if you want to do one
thing to anti-age, it's build connective
tissue. If you want to do one thing to
age gracefully, painlessly,
disease-free, build the connective
tissue. The connective tissue is made up
of protein fibers. The most important
one is called collagen and mush.
And that mush is like jelly. The mush
and the jelly are called extracellular
matrix.
>> And this extracellular matrix is
actually combination of the mush and the
jelly plus the fibers. That's the part
of the body you want to focus on for
anti-aging. The cartilage is a classic
example of that part of the body. So
everything you could do. By the way,
this was Dr. W before Dr. Wall who's the
mineral doctor. He was the connective
tissue doctor. That was his first thing.
He called it the pig pack or he called
the product the pig pack, right?
Remember the pig pack? I I think we
probably still have the pig pack.
>> So the pig What is the pig pack? And why
does he call it the pig pack?
>> Do you know why it's called the pig
pack? What? What is it about the pig
pack, AJ? What's Why is it the pig?
>> The tissues in it.
>> But why pig pack?
>> Because they call it couldn't call it a
human pack.
>> No, it's not. That's true. But why why
do you pick a pig? Because when you eat
connective tissue, that gives you the
raw materials and the signaling
molecules for building your connective
tissue. So he call it a pig pack because
it came from connective tissue of a pig.
>> Okay? You can have connective tissue of
a cow. You probably aren't going to eat
connective tissue from a human, but you
can have connective tissue from animals.
This is why indigenous cultures always
eat the organs.
We eat the muscle. When we eat meat, we
love the muscle. That's what steak is.
It's the muscle. We we get rid of the
the connective tissue. with the
connective tissue. Eating the connective
tissue, the the pig's feet, the snouts,
the tails, that's all the connective
tissue. When you eat connective tissue,
you build your connective tissue. He
called the pig pack because it had
connective tissue from a pig. And so, it
built your connective tissue. So, eating
connective tissue is job number one.
Now, you don't have to eat directly. You
don't have to eat, you know, organ meat
if you don't want organ meat or or um or
uh bone soup, bone broth. By the way,
bones are connective tissue. I was just
reading an article just um last week
earlier this week about how connected
building bone is not about calcium. It's
about building connective tissue which
we've been talking about here for years.
The bones are connective tissue. The
blood is connective tissue. The vessels
are connective tissue. So eating
connective tissue but you don't have to
necessarily eat the connective tissue.
You can eat your collagen peptides or
you can eat collagen. So that's another
thing that's another way to go. You can
eat the building blocks of connective
tissue. One of the most important is
glucosamine. So your gluccog caps. And
what you'll find is once you start
eating all these, not only you're
building your cartilage, but you're
building your fascia in your face, so
you get less wrinkles, you're building
your joints, so you get less arthritis.
The connective tissue feeds all the
cells. So every one of the cells of the
body is going to be healthier. The
connective tissues detoxifies.
So building connective tissue is the
sinan, the very essence of anti-aging is
building connective tissue. Focus on
that connective tissue. You can't build
connected tissue without your Beyond
Tangy Tangerine, specifically vitamin C.
So, make sure you're on your Beyond
Tangy Tangerine as well. Anything you
can do to build connected tissue, uh,
healthy bone, healthy bone and joint
pack, uh, and of course, Beyond Tangy
Tangerines in there. I'd throw in
collagen peptides, hydrayzeed collagen,
TMR. TMR is awesome. We haven't talked
about TMR in a while. That stuff is
awesome. Oh, yeah. For blood sugar, we
talked about eating more protein. Start
your meals off with TMR. Get some almond
milk, unsweetened, a banana,
and a couple scoops of a TMR shake. Holy
cow, is that delicious. Crack a raw egg
in there if you want more protein. Even
more delicious and healthy for you.
Start every meal off with some TMR
shake. Your body will love you. And Stan
and Laura will love you, too.
>> No doubt about it. No doubt about it.
Thank you.
>> Thank you so much. It sounds like I need
to turn this over to Ruth Ellen. And I I
do have to bolt here.
>> Yes, it is the top of the hour. Thank
you so much, Mary.
>> Thank you everybody.
>> All right. Thank you, Pharmacist Bend.
And
>> nice to see you all.
>> We'll see you next week.
>> Okay. Monday, AJ.
>> Yes. Monday.
>> Okay. Bye.
>> Bye. Thank you.
Thank you for joining us everyone. It
was a very um
informational packed show. We got lots
of questions answered and some really
good information in the beginning and um
I'm grateful that we were able to get
all those questions answered because
sometimes we run out of time. So, if I
can get my team to come up and join me
on the screen and I got to remember
there we go. All right.
Thank you everyone for joining us today.
Um, if your question did not get asked
or answered, um, please email us at
questions dot no questions at
dailywithdoc.com
and or you can call if you'd like to
speak with a certified holistic health
coach at 855-9493377
and somebody can help you. And also, if
you're working with somebody, please
make sure to get back with that person
uh because they'll be your primary point
of contact. And um also, this program
was for educational purposes only and
not meant to treat, diagnose, or cure
any diseases or replace your primary
care physician.
So, I want to thank everyone who came
and joined us today. Thank you for that.
Um, we love it when we get people coming
in and sh able to share information with
you. And I want to thank uh everyone who
helps support the show starting with
Mary.
Mary is out there on the different
platforms bringing in questions and
helping in the background here on the
Zoom. So, thank you so much for all that
you do, Mary. It's greatly appreciated.
And then we have Phyllis who is the
also doing that um but she's also
helping to share the platform uh on the
platforms in different areas and she is
also responsible her and her husband
Andy for getting Doc on the radio
otherwise none of us would probably be
here. So thank you for all that and so
much more fellas. And then we have
Marilyn who is Miss Speedy Fingers and
is and one of the benefits of being here
with us on Zoom is she is typing away
and um lots of information to read. So
thank you. Thank you Marilyn. You're
awesome. And then we have Albert who is
joining us from South Africa and is the
person that will answer the phone in the
middle of the night when the rest of us
are sleeping
because it's daytime to him. Thank you
for joining us, Albert. I know it's late
at night for you, so thank you. Thank
you. And also, he is the gatekeeper and
lets people in. And if you have a phone
number, he takes part of the phone
number off to guard your privacy, which
is very important to us. And then we
have AJ, who does too many things to
mention. He is our digital marketing
director and he just does so many things
and we are very grateful for him
especially
we enjoy pharmacist f uh Ben bites on
Monday night so join us for that and u
my name is Ruth Ellen Sanchez and I am
the executive productioner manager of
Daily with Doc and Becca and I do a lot
of things and I love what I do and I
love my team and I love everybody. And
Rebecca, we miss you.
Also, um just remember to be kind
because you don't know what somebody's
going through. And also it's very
important to respect people's wishes and
privacy
and not push and keep pushing if they
ask you to stop contacting them. So
please stop.
Anyway,
um we will see you all next week. We
have some great guests next week. So,
have a great and beautiful weekend
tomorrow. And if you are part of the
Institute of Holistic Health, graduation
is tomorrow at noon. Email us or text us
to find out where to go if you don't
already know. Thank you so much,
everybody. Have a beautiful day.
Bye, AJ.
>> Well, that was an opportunity. I mean,
you mentioned the Institute of Holistic
Health Graduate.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Yes. If you're interested
in being a coach, please go to
coach.dwithdoc.com
and there's information there and you
can join all of us and be a coach. Thank
you for that reminder, AJ. Thank you.
Have a great weekend, everyone.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine for
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor